for shows as dark and suspenseful as
ncis it's hard to imagine one scene's
subject matter seeming harder to watch
than the rest so what event could be so
heart-wrenching that it outshines an
entire season keep watching to discover
the one scene ncis season 9 took too far
as sad as it is to see familiar faces
leave one universal truth has emerged
ncis likes to craft dramatic exits for
its characters as time has gone on
audiences have gotten used to living
with the worry that something terrible
could happen to their favorite
investigator at any moment packed with
ups downs major plot twists and plenty
of ncis classic brand of drama season 9
is no exception to this gruesome
storytelling style in it we see
everything from tony denozzo played by
michael weatherly getting shot to cody
de pablo's character is eva david
receiving a marriage proposal in crime
dramas like ncis there are plenty of
scenes that may be difficult for some
audiences to watch especially while
experiencing the rest of the emotional
turmoil included in season 9. however
there is one particular scene involving
a major character that is almost too
shocking to talk about in ncis season 9
episode 24 tell death do us part it's
not a grisly crime scene or awkward
moment that leaves viewers reeling
instead audiences get a taste of this
show's trademark heartbreak when at the
end of this action-packed season finale
fan-favorite medical examiner donald
ducky mallard played by david mcgallum
has a heart attack the shocking event is
one of many packed into the hour-long
season finale and its placement in the
latter half of the episode only adds to
the tension till death do us part sees
gibbs and his team pull out all the
stops as they continue to investigate a
series of deadly explosions gibbs
recruits dr samantha ryan portrayed by
guest star jaime lee curtis to help
identify the cause soon a man named
harper dearing played by richard schiff
becomes the focus of the ncis team's
investigation in the final act deering's
last bomb goes off right outside ncis
headquarters the scene would be dramatic
enough by itself but it's only made
worse by the fact that gibbs mcgee ziva
dinozzo and abby are all trapped inside
by the damage in the episode's final
scene ducky is seen walking along the
beach as he takes in the view he
receives a call presumably about the
fatal bombing ducky demands that nobody
touches the bodies of the deceased then
pauses as a heart attack strikes
it's imperative that no one touch any of
the deceased until i
until i re
the last image of the season 9 finale
shows ducky collapsed on the beach as
the tide rolls in the heart attack seems
to be the result of overwhelming stress
from the shocking phone call and
audiences are left to wonder about
ducky's fate and the fate of all his
trapped team members the ncis season 9
finale ends so dramatically the fact
that it is stuck in the minds of fans
almost a decade after it aired should
come as no great surprise in june 2021
when a reddit user posed the question
any episodes of ncis that made you cry
fans had no trouble coming up with
plenty of iconic moments that hit a
little too close to home even still
ducky's heart attack made many viewers
list despite the 18 seasons of drama
they had to pick from when the thread
was posted a redditor included the scene
in their top three along with the deaths
of gibb's father and palmer's wife the
commenter went out to clarify there are
more that hug at the heart but these
three made me cry ducky is a vital
character in the series whose charm and
random educational banter has fans fully
invested in his well-being so watching
him have a heart attack in the ninth
season finale of ncis was a scene that
was a bit too much for some audience
members to handle
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]